i think i know why russia is the bad guy
why
because the u.s is cutting deals with
china and
not the us but these politicians oh yeah
for decades now our manufacturing has
been extracted
and we could thank nixon for this what
did nixon do i mean nixon went to china
in normalized relations he raised the
glass to chairman mao in a toast that
was written by papua kennedy geez really
yes yes and the thing is what people
don't appreciate this is what i hate
binary thinkers in politics
you know they think if i want right wing
ideas i'm going to vote right wing and
if i want left wings ideas
i vote left wing bill clinton gave a ban
on gay marriage in a balanced budget a
lot of times
because there's no one to a person's
left to criticize them they're in a
position to implement
right-wing ideas and vice versa richard
nixon who cut his teeth
running against uh helen douglas i think
was her name was for the senate and
called her a commie which she in some
way she probably was
no one's gonna say richard nixon's two
pro communists
so that gave him cover as president to
go to china i mean
mao is the biggest butcher in history
without question
yeah and raise a glass and like oh we're
friends now and
who's going to say he's not hard enough
on communism so it's this is something
that
a lot of times politics is very
counterintuitive but there's a very big
incentive for both political parties
to make it seem like it's this is left
this is right if you want right vote
right if you want left vote left
and that's not how it ends up look at
the spending this year there's been no
voices saying
what if it's just maybe 10 less no one
well trump has really broken the left
and the right of whatever it's supposed
to be oh yeah it used to you know you
know i think
that the way i view politics right now
and one of the reasons why
aside from the riots and the chaos i'm
like you know what man i'm voting for
trump there's a lot of reasons number
one is
the cult of intersectionality
identitarianism on the left is
like nightmarishly expansive it's just
getting worse it's maoism
it's it yeah there are struggle sessions
those are literal struggle sessions
my my fear is they want to rewind the
clock on civil rights
like i'm not even kidding they were
appealing 209 in uh prop 209 in
california which is their their public
civil rights law they're like we're
getting rid of this one and that that's
crazy to me
but one of the big deals uh particularly
is
is you know trump trying to remove our
troops yeah uh he tried doing it in
syria it's not worked out too well i
remember when he fired those tomahawks
at syria the 59 tomak missiles and i was
laughing like yeah of course here we go
again it's what presidents do
it's a big game and then also the media
was like oh is trump being presidential
yep of course we remember this very well
it's the first time he was being
presidential is when he's bombing
the country it's so but once you know
that that's what they believe
it's very disturbing because you see it
all the time so
trump is not a republican he's not a
republican the way i remember
republicans growing up
these these christian moral mitt romney
types
so i i view trump as
he's kind of like to me but i got
interrupted tim that's a myth the only
christian mitt romney type was jimmy
carter
who was a democrat reagan was reagan was
divorced
uh george hw right but there were none
the thing is that's the image but none
of them were really there that's not i
don't necessarily mean
i'm giving a caricature okay sure
obviously i don't think all the
republicans were like you know
hoity-toity christian
uptight i think it was like you know
when i was growing up the republicans
were very moral authoritarian oh yeah
and so now that's kind of drifted away
and we're seeing a more like
republicans are becoming a bit more
libertarian sure and they're kind of
you know less about imposing their
morals in other people whereas the left
is doing all that now
each party is libertarian when they're
in the defensive and then when they get
in power they become authoritarian
because now they're in a position to do
what they want
well i don't i don't i don't think trump
is whatever that established
party was i agree and i think they're
mad we're seeing all these republicans
resign retire
you know no not responsibilities not
john kasich please come back john
and now they're all endorsing biden you
know what you know you know why i see
what it is or the way i see it
that both parties were like uh you you
know that futurama episode you want to
be trauma of course where the where the
uh jack johnson and john jackson yeah of
course yes
yeah i think you're you know he was like
or don't blame me i voted for kodos
yeah yeah but the the the future on my
joke is um i think your tax proposal
goes too far
i think your tax proposal doesn't go too
far enough like that you don't even know
what they're talking about
so i post i remember i posted this meme
a long time ago on facebook got a ton of
shares
it's an image of a guy on a sing on a
couch with his with his girlfriend and
she's got his arm around him and then
his arm is behind the couch holding the
hands of a of a different woman
and so i put you know uh democrats
republicans
you and you're you're on your party like
loving them and they're secretly working
together yeah
of course the the republicans like the
republican establishment and the
democratic establishment were in
agreement on war
and you know this this intervention and
all of these things
and then trump comes in and it's kind of
wild and all over the place
now he's sort of no new war no no new
wars trying to pull our troops out it's
it's
it's a part of his second term agenda he
actually tried to do it and now they're
going nuts
he's been going nuts the whole time for
sure here's the other thing if you were
wrong by your own admission about the
biggest foreign policy decision in the
last 30 years which was the iraq war if
this is by your own words this was a
mistake
mistake means like oh tim i was supposed
to pay you back i forgot the money oops
buddy you never said like that i'm late
it's not i'm responsible for the deaths
of hundreds of thousands of people
let's even pretend iraqi lives don't
matter which a lot of times people
actually do and how many soldiers
if that's the case if your judgment is
that flawed
you're not in a position to try to be
commander-in-chief you would have actual
guilt and be like what have i done like
you and i both know people
who were had their finger in leading up
to the iraq war
and who look back at that and they're
still filled with enormous guilt
as well they should be if you thought of
this as a mistake if you had your hand
in the iraq war
and you think of it a mistake in the
same way you and i and many other people
think of a mistake
you're not running for president you're
going to therapy because you're like how
can i sleep at night
where because of my vote so many people
lost their kid
i don't think they care right right they
don't care but what i'm saying is if it
really was a mistake
an insane person would be like oh my god
what have i done so so so
what do you think about trump i mean
this i could go on for hours would you
let's
be more specific in this context do you
think trump
is trying to do right by america i i
think in this context trump has been
very consistent
in being anti-war i think they
they're the corporate press and the
cathedral always like to portray
themselves
as sophisticated right oh you don't
understand yours
you watch your big bang theory in peoria
we read the new yorker and we watch
listen npr
we're sophisticated and obvi you know
the the arguments for war are often
complex although they're dishonest
and it's like wait a minute this idiot
is saying
what's the point of going to war can
someone sit him down and explain it
because i sure can't
yeah you can't because you're a liar
because there isn't a reason
so the fact that he has this very basic
aversion to war
the fact that he's like explain to me
why we have to be
everywhere on earth my friend had this
idea
and i think this would be brilliant if
the commander-in-chief
uh you know halloween october 15th says
you know what these troops should be
spending christmas with their families
i'm pulling them from all over the world
and they can vote by the way
and let the press freak out like oh my
god it's going to stabilize the world
and let all these americans be like that
is how patriots
operate and this would be an enormous
boon for him and
it would drop their mask even further
for their malfeasance and depravity
let them justify why they're in these
yeses why are we in germany
yeah the hell are you talking it was it
was so it was so funny when that
happened because you know uh trump
talked about getting our troops out of
afghanistan and germany
and the intercept i'm like you know this
is what's crazy to me
why aren't they more in favor of trump
take the win when you can take it yeah
if if you are adamant about getting our
troops back
and you're willing to criticize
democrats and republicans for blocking
trump from doing so
then maybe you shouldn't jump on all of
the insane corporate press smears of the
president
to make money do you remember that when
we assassinated general solomony that
was going to be world war
iii yeah that was a given he was there
you know george washington
i can't believe he killed this guy what
have we done they're going to nuke
israel
they're not going to back down but then
they back down no one who said
that we would have these disastrous
consequences
has paid any price for their at least
ever
this uh uh confusion let alone lies
you know that's that's why russia needs
to be the specter if we pull our troops
out of germany
russia will move in russia's not going
to invade germany
germany that's ridiculous now russia did
invade crimea sure
you know we can talk about that but we
didn't do anything then right and that
was a long time ago right
so ultimately i ask you the question
about trump
in in kind of the term terms of i don't
know how you how
would you vote for trump i don't believe
in voting no you don't know
okay well i guess how do i ask you that
question then
what do what do you think of his job
like do you think he's done a good job
i think what he's best at is dropping
getting them to drop their mask
and i think what he's best at is
something i'm very big and heavily in
favor of
is uh eliminating political discourse
and having the this idea this
boomer con fantasy that everyone's gonna
sit down and it's gonna be reagan and
tip o'neill
and we're gonna just shake our hands and
come to compromise when the parties work
together
america gets screwed it is very very
useful for them
to despise each other in real life a lot
of times they despise each other for
fake like in wrestling
i'm old enough to remember when people
found out that jim do hacksaw jim duggan
and the iron sheik were in a car
together they got arrested he's a bad
guy he's a good guy this is
unconscionable
this changes everything you mean kamala
isn't really a cannibal from africa who
eats chickens
um it blew everyone's mind and a lot of
that is fake
and for the cameras lindsey graham is a
great example he was losing his mind by
kavanaugh yeah
where where have been this julie
swetnick summons where have been
accountability people i'd call them a
gang rape because they're being i don't
like any of these
right exactly so they put on a good show
and whatever but
he is uh i think showing a lot of people
that
there's large segments of the left who
want you dead
but will settle for your submission and
it's become and
the fact that you would have let's go
back to the atlantic
if i were as an entity responsible
for getting us into the great war and
felt some remorse about this century-old
mistake
nowadays they'd be like you know what
this is our background i'm going to err
on the side of caution and air on the
side of non-interventionism
because i got a lot of explaining to do
and a lot of making effort but they
don't
because they are proud of their
depravity well they're well i think
they're proud of world war ii oh sure
but that that was in the atlantic world
war one was large no i mean i mean
you you get an example but they couldn't
get us into world war ii it took the
japanese
right but i think after world war ii
they can justify you see here's what
happened oh yeah and there's there's a
legitimate question about how do we deal
with china
i mean look like they have no good
answers i don't think there are any good
answers on the table they're not a paper
tiger they're
enormously powerful they're incredibly
vindictive they do not value human life
and that's and when you have a billion
people you know value human life that's
things that very very tricky very
quickly i hear a lot of people say that
china is a paper tiger
and i'm like that's as far as i'm
concerned they're relevant because they
have economic power yeah they can
buy the the you know they've got rock
lobster or whatever they've got a huge
military
and that's and the thing is they they're
also in a position to do
they've got nukes i mean a paper tiger
or not this the and these people are are
very it's very important for them not to
lose face in the public eye so
these are very dangerous stakes one of
we this is a good opportunity to segue
into like the riots and stuff because
one of one of the things i've pointed
out we mentioned we're talking a little
bit
about this before the show there's a lot
of things that have happened because of
covet and the riots that have benefited
us
if it comes to war notably that our
cities are decentralized yes
our economy is becoming remote workers
making it very hard to destabilize
and people are armed to the teeth we've
gotten rid of non-essential jobs
and a lot of the jobs that are coming
back first are the ones that are
for the most part more essential than
others and some jobs have permanently
closed that weren't as essential which
means
a lot of people are now going to be
seeking out work that will be more in
line with essential activities
these things together that's gonna help
us out a lot if it comes to war and
there's been
uh there's something i often refer to
called the thucydides trap
this has just been referenced in the
media over and over again are you have
you familiar with the
is that the one with the boat through
city strap no it's the it's it's
i don't know the exact reference of why
it is you know named this but the
general idea is
when a rising economic power approaches
the dominant power war breaks out okay
and it's like
i think the atlantic to the story is
saying over the past 500 years there
have been 16 moments and 12 of them
resulted in war
so one of the arguments i hear from the
people who are pro like the
trans-pacific partnership
the these you're familiar with the tv
and the trade deals was that it would
prevent war from breaking out by
creating strong economic ties between
the two countries
send all our factories over to china we
can't go to war with them they'll rise
and become the dominant superpower but
who cares we're all rich oh that's
that's a very disturbing
i mean that's one of the arguments who
cares if the chinese oh my god that's
horrifying
the idea was what is the i mean i'm
going to get all christians but what
value is the price of money if it cost
of your soul i mean this is that's what
scares me
that's a depraved nation well so state
the government i mean
right but the people there are people
who genuinely argue
war is bad we don't want death and
if we have these trade lines between the
us and china it will disincentivize war
because people would lose money because
we still get death because when you have
a totalitarian regime the oppression i
know amount of people and that's killed
it's my god and if they take over
yes so so bernie and trump oppose tpp
okay now bernie
right he sold out to the dnc as soon as
he could of course you know he doesn't
say millionaires anymore
is that right right that's just
billionaires you say a million as a
billionaire yeah it's just billionaires
he's a millionaire yeah i'm assuming
that's the reason but he's he's totally
in line endorsed them
every step of the way but trump is very
much he shut it down he shut down nafta
and it seems like whether trump has the
ability to do so or not whether he's
sporadic or not he does want to help
this country
there's also an example in american
shores which is alexander hamilton's
brilliant idea was to have a national
bank and nationalize the debt
because he said this would be a great
blessing because when you have
the debt of 13 states interwound you
can't unwind it
so it's going to be a country whereas if
you had 13 states 30
currencies it's very easy to separate
apart right to the point where jefferson
who was like a huge enemy of this he's
like this is unconstitutional
he backed up having the national bank as
president and what that led to
70 years later was a civil war this idea
that economic entanglements
are going to be a guarantee against war
maybe against war but it's sure not
going to be a guarantee against conflict
and we saw it thankfully the other
peaceful way with brexit
where they voted for brexit but then
implementing it took two years because
no one could negotiate in terms of
divorce successfully
oh yeah i mean it was i think it was
more than that it was
yeah it's extended period of time yeah
it felt like a betrayal from the
the politicians from parliament theresa
may is just like
i'm really happy that she's going to go
down history as one of the worst
politicians
in history you know what happened what
is it december 13th 2019 in the uk
no insane landslide victory oh yeah of
course yeah yeah yes
you think that's coming here no you
don't think so no i don't think so
like like the house flipping republican
senate going
you know no i don't i mean it's very
different with a parliament because
basically the parliament is the
equivalent of our house of
representatives
right and you had jeremy corbyn which
people don't appreciate to what extent
jeremy corbyn is a despicable evil
person who
validated enormous anti-semitism and
radicalism he was like a stalinist right
yeah
joe biden it's very hard to hate him in
terms of politics he's not a bad person
he might be an
idiot or a mass or many things it's very
hard to make the case this guy is a
radical
my favorite joe biden is angry old man
joe biden there was a
uh look fat joe biden no an activist an
activist got in his face and said you
need open borders
biden turned his back and he said go
vote for trump go for trump
like stuff like that i mean he's much
more old school i mean the guy's been in
the senate
since 19 since nixon so he put
a lot of black people in jail uh he
gotten bill yeah he got clarence thomas
on the supreme court to some extent i
mean he didn't fight it or whatever
his role was in that so he has a rec i
mean he's
talking the nonsensical talk now just
yesterday he was claiming that a black
person invented a light bulb
this is just pure is that what he said
yes this is pure out of this kind of
revisionist history
where a you know population is the most
oppressed in history
but also the greatest inventor
simultaneously somehow
but this has been common parlance with
this kind of howard zinn
uh far lefty and joe biden just you know
being a good politician and talking to
talk
but it's going to be very hard to
compare him to
jeremy corbyn because jeremy corbyn i
don't think we have any american analog
in terms of how what a nasty person he
is and how uncharismatic
and how radical his ideas were i have a
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time